euh vous l'avez suivi Bruno Darou vous
le dit biens qui a également réitérer
ses demandes d'adhésion a lieu et à
l'OTAN réitérer donc puisque en fait une
visite en deux temps mais que les
téléspectateurs de France 24 ont pu
suivre il y avait d'abord un vraiment un
discours proprement dit qui n'était pas
une conférence de presse sur l'aspect
juridique la CPI la Cour Pénale à
l'international et vous l'avez dit
effectivement
voilà ce qui souhaite la mise en place
d'un d'un tribunal spécial
identique un peu à celui qui a été créé
à la fin secondaire mondiale le tribunal
de Nuremberg il a d'ailleurs fait un
parallèle avec le nazisme bon qui est
questionnable mais enfin bon c'est c'est
son point de vue le nazisme qui est
instrumentalisé hautement et par Kef et
par Moscou dans cette guerre et puis là
alors effectivement c'était une
conférence de presse avec le Premier
ministre néerlandais Marc routeux et là
effectivement il a été question de lieu
et de l'OTAN de l'adhésion de l'Ukraine
à l'Union européenne et de l'adhésion de
l'Ukraine à l'OTAN qui sont donc deux
processus différents bon on n'a pas
appris grand chose sinon que vous le
ditersky réaffirmé avec force le fait
que concernant l'OTAN notamment il
attendait du projet du prochain sommet
de l'organisation de l'Alliance
atlantique qui se tient au mois de
juillet à Vilnius que ce soit plus qu'un
sommet de la porte ouverte mais que donc
l'OTAN prenne davantage d'engagement
alors on n'a pas bien compris quels
étaient ces engagements puisqu'en même
temps les deux dirigeants ont reconnu le
fait que tant que l'Ukraine était en
guerre et ben il ne pouvait pas y avoir
d'adhésion à l'OTAN puisque les les le
traité l'OTAN si vous voulez spécifique
un pays qui adhère doit être en paix et
que ces frontières doivent être
définitivement établies ce qui
évidemment n'est pas le cas c'est ce que
reconnait
voilà l'Ukraine et en même temps il dit
il faut que le sommet de l'OTAN nous
fasse davantage de propositions donc
est-ce que ça veut dire par exemple un
engagement
dès la fin de la guerre à des ions de
l'Ukraine à l'OTAN par exemple voilà on
en saura peut-être un peu plus alors sur
l'Union européenne c'est un processus
plus graduel vous savez il y a les
fameux chapitres à égrainer avant une
adhésion à l'Union européenne d'habitude
ça prend plusieurs années là on sent
clairement qu'il y aura un premier point
d'étape par la Commission européenne au
mois d'octobre on sent clairement que ça
pourrait aller plus vite que la
procédure habituelle mais là aussi
soyons réalise Julien il y aura
certainement pas d'adhésion de l'Ukraine
à l'Union européenne avant la fin de la
guerre disons que là aussi on est en
processus accéléré en tout cas
de dire que l'Ukraine a là l'engagement
de principe quand même très fort que à
la fin de la guerre finalement elle
rejoindra l'OTAN elle rejoindra l'Union
européenne c'est-à-dire exactement ce
que voulait éviter Vladimir Poutine en
lançant son invasion à grande échelle la
guerre qui est loin d'être terminée
est-ce qu'on a pris davantage sur la
contre-offensive que préparait les
Ukrainiens oui alors sur cette
contre-offensive on a on n'a pas appris
évidemment quand et commence à aller se
passer puisque voilà ce qui évidemment a
dit vous comprendrez que je ne vous
donne pas les détails on sent vraiment
que les Ukrainiens sont sur le point d'y
aller évidemment volody muriels qui se
montre très optimiste il pense que cette
contre-offensive ne sera peut-être pas
quand même un succès total enfin au
point où l'attend l'état-major ukrainien
mais que ce sera un succès car dit-il
nos adversaires les soldats russes en
face sont dans un état de très grande
démotivation et donc il est évidemment
très confiant dans cette offens qui doit
lui permettre de récupérer ses
frontières alors ça veut dire aussi
peut-être que la Crimée fera partie de
cette contre-offensive mais franchement
il n'a pas il n'a pas davantage spécifié
et puis il a reparlé de de la fin du
conflit en estimant que il était il a
dit quand même là assez clairement il
était hors de question de négocier avec
Vladimir Poutine donc là c'est un
message assez fort qui l'envoie à
certains dirigeants occidentaux qui
disent vous savez il faut pas humilier
la Russie enfin alors lui il est pas
pour humilier la Russie mais il est
clairement pas pour discuter avec la
lumière Poutine à la tête de la Russie
puisqu'il a même employé l'expression de
la nécessité d'un changement de régime
avant de négocier merci beaucoup Bruno